this is worse than an excruciatingly
painful movie about somebody getting
older in life and now both our allies
and our adversaries they see exactly
what we've been telling you night after
night after night biden is weak frail
decrepit and he's a cognitive wreck
who's not up to the job of commander in
chief which is the most demanding job in
the world here with reaction louisiana
senator john kennedy is with us senator
um
i think he's going over there to kiss
the ass of the crown prince i think he's
going over there to beg for oil and i
think he's going to try
and convince israel and saudi arabia
that doing business with iran is going
to be a good thing for the world which
is the dumbest idea i think of as of
today
well sean uh president biden clearly is
struggling he struggled today in the
middle east and i take no joy in that
um i trust the american people and i
think the american people
have figured things out i don't
i don't consider my
myself an expert in too many things if
any but i know how to read a poll
and a majority of americans
for to them the president is about as
popular as cholera
and and the american people didn't just
reach this conclusion this morning they
have reasons for believing that
number one
a majority of americans don't believe
that president biden is in charge
they think the president is not the
president
they think that the real president is uh
whoever controls the teleprompter
number two uh fair or unfair
a majority of americans think that
president biden is too old
um they think he's kind of like an old
buick you know some days he starts and
and other days he doesn't
um number three
a majority of americans think that the
people that president biden has
appointed to run his government are
deeply weird and they are
many of these appointees
they curl up in a protective ball if you
use the wrong pronoun
they pride themselves on not prosecuting
criminals
their uh their executive skills
extend no further than ordering a pizza
but
the the the
laughing it's true
is and and the american people sooner or
later they figure this stuff out
the final point i'd make is the american
people are are
they're very disappointed in president
biden and his policies a majority of
americans believe that he has mismanaged
congress he's mismanaged coving he's
mismanaged the border he's mismanaged
immigration he's mismanaged crime he's
mismanaged america's energy independence
he's mismanaged afghanistan he's
mismanaged the economy and he's
mismanaged inflation
uh inflation is waterboarding the
american people their people are scared
they're not going to be able to retire
until they're 92 their 401 have crashed
and and it doesn't it doesn't give me
joy to say this but but the american
people figure it out sooner or later and
that's why at the moment
um
how can i put this the um
the creepy banjo kid in deliverance is
more popular than the president at the
moment and he better reverse direction
soon it's hurting america and it's
hurting him he's not go but senator he's
not going to reverse course you know
he's not hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else